and maybe that's why they weren't and
aren't focused on very real security
failures at the Capitol on January 6th
or maybe it's because a prominent
Democrat is to blame for those security
failures according to the former Capitol
Police Chief Steven Sun who will join us
in a minute the house sergeant-at-arms
turned down his National Guard requests
prior to January 6 because quote I will
never get this by Pelosi joining us now
with more the author of the brand new
book it's called courage Under Fire
former Capitol Police Chief Steven Sund
is with us sir thank you for being here
number one uh I'm sorry what happened to
you your fellow officers that day
it breaks my heart a lot of my family
has been in law enforcement when any law
enforcement officers that is hurt
I'll let you tell the story how many
times in total do you remember recall
requesting the National Guard
well first of all Sean thank you very
much for having me on tonight and I
really appreciate you kind of talking
about the 2020 riots coming up to
January 6th is that something I tie
together in my book
um there was a number of uh requests I
went on January 3rd requesting uh the
National Guard from Paul Irving that was
the first request for the for the
National Guard I then went to Mike
Stinger who's the Senate Sergeant arms
now Paul Irving is politically appointed
by Speaker Pelosi he initially when I
asked for the National Guard on January
3rd which was a Sunday was the first day
of the new Congress he said specifically
quote I don't like the Optics and
besides the intelligence didn't support
it his concern for the Optics I believe
goes back to Pelosi's decision there um
statement that she referred to as
federal agents in National Guard on the
trail on streets of America as
Stormtroopers and I think she just
didn't want the look of Storm Troopers
up on the hill and then come January 6th
and I think what your what Your viewers
don't under realize is the restrictions
I have is the chief of police I'm one of
the only Chiefs in the United States I
am the only Chief in the United States
that has a federal law a law passed by
members of Congress that prevents me
from calling in any federal resources
either in advance like I try to do on
January 3rd or even while I'm under
attack without going and getting the
politically appointed Sergeant arms
approval so at 12 53 we're attacked on
the west front of the Capitol I'm
watching my officers getting brutally
beaten I pick up the phone at 12 55 I
call MPD for assistance there are our
partner agency right right next door and
then at 12 58 I call Paul Irving speaker
Pelosi's appointee to the Capitol Police
board and tell them it's really bad on
on the uh can I interrupt you is it the
Speaker of the House in charge of
security at the Capitol
so you have the politically appointed
Capitol Police board that's put in place
by the sergeant arms that's put in place
by Pelosi you have the Senate Sergeant
arms are put in place by the Senate
leadership and then you have the
architect of the capital that's put in
place by the the president so you have
three voting members I'm a non-voting
member I'm the only non-politically
appointed non-voting member uh and
that's kind of how the security
oversight works but it was Paul Irving
who immediately said I'm going to run it
up the chain I'll never forget that
running up the chain of his chain of
command ends at speaker Pelosi and I had
to wait 71 minutes to finally get an
approval at 2 at 209 PM before I could
finally reach out and start calling in
federal assistance 71 minutes woman men
and women fought on the uh brutally I
mean fought heroically to prevent the
capital from being defended I mean from
being penetrated and it took 80 minutes
before the first window was broken so
those were critical essential minutes
that we're losing
let me go back a little bit and it was a
number of days out of January 6th and
the issue of the National Guard first
came up and you had not seen enough
intelligence that convinced you that you
would need the guard at that time within
a day or two later correct me if my
timeline is wrong my understanding is
that new intelligence came in that
alarmed you to such a degree that you
felt they would absolutely need the
guard we would need other law
enforcement help for the Capitol Police
is that how is that the timeline is that
an accurate timeline no that's uh that's
actually not how it played out so
January 3rd the morning of January third
I went over to see uh Paul Irving at 9
34 a.m in the morning to request the
National Guard uh the final intelligence
assessment didn't come out to the
evening of January 3rd it was pretty
much reviewed maybe on the fourth but
you got to understand that intelligence
assessment didn't even indicate the
level of threat that we now know uh
existed the significant threat that was
out there the fact that these FBI was
tracking 18 domestic
terrorist suspects that were coming to
the Capitol and my intelligence unit on
the fourth fifth and sixth put out
intelligence I was saying low
probability of Civil Disobedience and
what's interesting is is my my Deputy
Chief and assistant chief over
intelligence even had me approve
recommended approval for the permits
that were taking place on Capitol
grounds most of those approvals came
through on the fourth so you know here
we are the fifth I've got a big video
call with all the heads of intelligence
law enforcement agencies from the
District of Columbia as well as military
leadership in in DC and no one's no
one's setting up the blue balloon or
ringing any alarms about the
intelligence so my request for the
National Guard was based on my law
enforcement experience I knew I had a
large perimeter I knew we were going to
have the vice president uh up on the
hill as well as well as both joint
sessions of Congress in uh in place and
it was going to take a lot of my
Staffing so I knew I didn't have
significant Staffing for the perimeter
and that's why I wanted the National
Guard to help stand on the perimeter to
help defend let me ask you this
but because I just played in full that
NBC news report that our our top law
enforcement agencies our top
intelligence agencies had information
about people plotting planning and
scheming and attack for that day in
other words they knew this was a real
clear and present danger
um and yet
there were no reinforcements sent to you
it seems like they left you hanging out
there to dry in retrospect hearing that
what does that mean to you
well I find that very concerning I mean
having done many events I mean I've
handled numerous inaugurations uh
numerous nsses I've never seen
intelligence handled this way before and
for events with far lesser threat
streams usually the FBI would do a
briefing a joint intelligence bulletin
would call and uh do a video a
conference call even none of that
occurred now we're finding out DHS you
know failed to share information but my
own intelligence unit didn't put some of
the significant integens that I now know
they they had into their final
assessments that could have been done
I was just going to say to better
prepare us
yeah what do you do what did you think
of the mayor uh declining uh the calling
up the guard under any circumstances
until she said it was okay by that point
it was way too late
well I find that concerning I find
concerning the memorandum that's put in
place restricting any National Guard
from carrying any Civil Disobedience
equipment but I think the mayor's
mayor's letter goes hand in hand with
what speaker Pelosi didn't want to see
the the Storm Troopers out on the
streets so it really tied our hands uh
that day and you know looking back at
the way you started into this talk about
the January 6 committee what people need
to realize there's the restrictions I
had as the chief and ask yourself why
the January 6 committee never requested
that I come and publicly testify think
about that I'm the chief of the Capitol
Police to have me come down and publicly
testify before the January 6th committee
because I think they were concerned it
would begin to show what went on the six
one on the days leading up to the six
and what was the involvement of
political leadership in their appointees
wow what this this is a story that
should have been highlighted and frankly
we should have more security measures in
place immediately that should be a top
priority uh you agree with that last
part I have to run I absolutely agree
sir hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else